rich is joining us now uh live from
cleveland
rich i'm hoping the weather's going to
be fantastic for you guys i've heard
there might be some stuff going on there
what are we looking at
well dan i've got um hey guys um
hey well i'm hanging in there i miss you
guys it's bill twofold
is is he actually working today no no
he's awesome
when the boss is away the boys will play
oh my gosh
uh but i'm doing i'm doing uh the mock
draft show uh dj daniel jeremiah was on
our show yesterday
and um and uh tonight is the the mock
draft
at eight eastern time uh but at five
bells local time here in ohio we're
getting a a
call from nfl network production to see
if uh we have to call an omaha an
audible
and do the show from me and dj
in a uh a radio booth
in the stadium and then charles and
kurt warner have to go to the science
museum set
that they've got set up because a
lightning storm
may hit the area um right when we're
going on the air
oh boy it is it is an awful
weather system coming into uh ohio
that definitely 100 chance of rain for
the draft
tomorrow it is going to be a waterlogged
first round so i guess
if you're all about hair uh it's a good
thing trevor's not gonna be here
tomorrow
because it would be a very bad hair day
for trevor lawrence based on the weather
well the good news rich is you're in the
clear in that department
you know what i mean you know what dan
you know i know you got the dimples
sitting in my chair and all that stuff
but a little respect that's true you
shouldn't ruffle the feathers of the
of the man who
we're all about the brotherhood you know
uh
and again out of all the uh studio hosts
nominated for the emmy this year uh
rachel nichols is the only one with hair
so
of the brotherhood um but yes it's going
to be a very
nasty uh weather day but
uh it's still going to go down outside
they're all set to go
uh the commissioner will be here i'm
told that i'm interviewing him tomorrow
uh in his green room and they did in
fact
god bless the nfl for the commissioner's
green room they did bring the same
barker lounger chair from his
basement that he did the draft in last
year so i'm told that that's what he'll
be sitting in when i interview him
tomorrow
oh it's correct it'll be uh that'll be
tomorrow well there there's certainly
rich is it's the best reality show on
television and
there are so many story lines um none
more
uh important and uh bigger than the
quarterbacks
obviously and there have been years rich
as you remember
i remember the johnny manziel draft
where there was
a lack of kind of quarterbacks and you
know all the pre-draft shows we had to
make sure that we got
johnny manziel in there because that was
a big storyline as you know
that's not the issue this year you you
will be talking you'll be quarterback
heavy
in the top ten we may see a draft like
we've never seen before
that is correct you know and there
there's no doubt like with
as you know the phrase it pays on our
show uh with all due respect
uh which now allows me to be
disrespectful um
the anytime a defensive end
or a left tackle is the top pick in the
draft you just cannot
compare it with a draft that has a
quarterback at the top or two
quarterbacks at the top or
in this case three quarterbacks at the
top 1999 being the last time that that
happened
and there's never been four in a row um
and you know uh interestingly enough the
trey lance
uh is truly the choice of the 49ers is
gaining more steam since i've walked
um into the uh the draft city um
and justin fields as well um
you know so we're hearing all about that
um
everybody that i'm speaking to here
believes kyle pitts
is the choice for atlanta fourth overall
um and um
you know we're we're we're wondering how
many defensive players will go in the
top ten
uh is essentially you know i i i doubt
that number even cracks
you know two uh they'll be i'd be
stunned if
three defensive players went in the top
ten um
and you know there's only been one case
of one defensive player going in the top
ten
and uh that was 1969 the year i was
born and that one player was mean joe
green so at least
it was a hall of famer um and we may
rival that tomorrow night that may
actually be
a record that's tied tomorrow night
well we know we're going to see another
record that's tied in terms of
quarterbacks going one two three you
mentioned the last time
that happened was 1999 it's only
happened one other time in history
and that was 71. it was jim plunkett
archie manning uh and
dan pastorini and then in 99 it was
couch mcnabb and akili smith and we talk
about
that 50 50 hit rate all the time that's
basically 50 50 right there those six
guys three of them were successful and
three of them were not
um in the nfl we saw a trade that just
went down
um a short time ago teddy bridgewater
because of sam darnold's presence
in carolina traded to the denver broncos
for a sixth round pick
your good buddy adam schefter uh
tweeting after tom pelicero broke the
story by the way
uh golf clap for tom there i'm breaking
that one uh but after tweeting that that
doesn't change
denver's approach in the draft they
could still potentially
draft a qb at nine or potentially even
move up right
that's that that's another i mean yeah
that's true too um
you know and uh to me that sounds like
insurance
that um all five quarterbacks could go
um it's entirely possible like if you're
denver's sitting there at nine
and carolina is swearing they're going
to take a quarterback
at eight and that that you know to use
the mantra that
you know hey just because we acquired a
quarterback doesn't mean we won't draft
one
um and then you've got detroit sitting
there at seven
and you're john elway and you think i'm
definitely gonna get one of these five
quarterbacks and you wake up
and you're like oh i may not maybe
that's one way to assure yourself of
i will at least go into the season with
teddy bridgewater and drew locke
i will at least have a veteran that is
going to push drew lock i will at least
have a veteran
who's also a great human that will be in
a an excellent quarterback room for my
team
i've got that in my back pocket
um and also if somebody drops
or somebody can sit there at nine or
somebody
does accept john elway's trade offer
then he'll go get that guy and then
i guess via condios to drew lock um
there's a lot of quarterbacks that are
sitting around you know with jobs
nervous right now and
sam darnold could be one of them i i
just don't see that i i
i don't know man i i just see carolina
having so many needs
um i i could see them uh ruining your
night tj
uh we're not ruining you know um just
upsetting your apple carter and then
taking certain
um eighth overall i could see that you
know where you've got darnold and you've
got
you know all the receivers named moore
and you've got robbie anderson and you
got christian mccaffrey and you've got
sam darnold go get
the defensive help and go to go to work
so putting it all together you know it
makes sense that denver
grabs bridgewater they at least have
somebody there in their their
quarterback room to either push
mentor or supplant dru lock
and see what happens tomorrow night um
and see what works
you've been talking incessantly about
the the scenarios and the quarterbacks
and the players
let's peel back the curtain a little bit
for those who are like me
who are fans of you fans of the process
broadcasting the show right so it's
draft day
walk me through what thursday's going to
be like for rich eisen who will be
hosting all the coverage of course on
nfl network
from the time you get up until you're
out there sitting at the desk wherever
you're going to be
in a broadcast booth because it's
raining or the original plan
okay uh it'll start with me uh popping
awake
way sooner than i really want to because
my children aren't here to ruin
everything
uh and i say that uh with the ultimate
of love of course
um and the best dad ever signed did you
keep that up
it's right here brother i want to be the
best dad ever too yeah it's right here
we got it again have you know shane
that's my i know i know
i know i know but so but you understand
like when you're on the road and your
your kids aren't here
way too soon um so i'll be doing that
um and then just you know uh puttering
around my hotel room because we're
quarantined
um i'll go um you know grab some
free lunch because that's what we do of
course
and then i'll go over a whole bunch of
uh
notes that i probably won't use
uh make sure that i have all the
pronunciators down correct
hope that it's not pouring rain hey
pause for a minute pause for a minute
rich because that that's that's
such an important part of the game is
you you have to get these guys names
right
are there a couple that are giving you a
little trouble that you're gonna make
sure you enunciate very clearly
no uh no and and the problem is
is that um my my issue is that whenever
it's
always something that's difficult for me
to pronounce
uh i just look at brockman and make him
do it
[Laughter]
no brockman at the draft though chris
do you why don't i do this why don't i
send
chris uh why don't i send um ryan leaf
who's doing tomorrow's show or don bowie
our producer
uh a list of names and see if you can
pronounce them
uh when it's time oh that's great it's a
great segment
tomorrow's show did we do that before
what do you think i don't mean to
produce the show from afar
chris no this is this is uh this this is
a great segment
uh i mean you're not going to be here
for the kentucky derby post unveiling
like we normally do
that is this weekend as well but that is
the birth of american pharoah which i
found not mistaken was our first
chicago draft show 2015. 2015.
so yeah i know i but that says you know
we've got a crack nfl network research
staff that can help me get hooked on
phonics and spell everything out
phonetically so
i'll be i'll be set to go but in in all
honesty tomorrow is just going to be
um just wishing it would start you know
i mean it is such an exciting night um
certainly since um you know it'll be a
literal damper
but uh the the rain i'm sure will not
keep a lot of the crazy
browns fans uh out um you know
out of the by the way special vaccinated
area that there are for fans that are
coming here um
and so that they'll still be fans there
but it's
you know we we missed it last year there
wasn't in person last year and then we
at nfl network missed it last year and
we're all fired up i mean everybody that
you know dan is just
through the roof we're jumping out of
our skin and and it's an exciting draft
and
all of those quarterbacks the top you
know will push a lot of very
talented players into the teams of this
draft
um so i i will be just spending much of
a day just
going over notes one last time calling
into this show as well doing whatever
phone calls i
also need to make to keep the the
charity run
uh coffers going and then i i'll head
over to the draft site probably around
four the commissioner's stopping by
around 5
30 or i'm finding him and then we're on
the air at seven
and then you know uh brown's on the
clock i mean the jaguars on the clock at
eight
and um and off we go and then it's just
you take a deep breath you
ex inhale and you exhale right around
saturday afternoon
early evening i love it and the red run
rich run uh
great idea this year was that your idea
to have all the
the legends come in and run with you or
or do you want to give somebody else
credit for that
no i i will definitely uh share the
credit with mark glory the
entrepreneur and who you know is now uh
owning the timberwolves soon and
you know he ran with uh jerry rice last
year he wanted to run
um against jerry at the combine and as
we walked off
the field last year he's like you know i
can get more people
who can donate and if you can get more
um
players who want to run we can make this
bigger um
and so when the combine got cancelled it
was like now what
uh the network still wanted to do it i
still wanted to do it mark lori still
wanted to run
i'm like if you can start kicking the
tires on
on getting more of your donors up
i'll get things started on the on the
nfl front tracy perlman from the nfl who
you know runs the nfl legends
sure a community and seven more showed
up
um and seven more mark lori's friends
showed up and
we did it at so far two weeks ago and
you know you're beginning to see the
footage
that um that uh that we're starting to
tweet out
and you'll see the content of
everybody's run on saturday um
a first cut of the piece i'm seeing it
later on today i'm excited to see it
it'll all be out there and now over 1.5
million now
i checked that link uh every now and
then too so fantastic
nfl.com well
it is uh such a great thing you've been
doing and continue to do you're the only
man in america who gets faster as you
as you age which is a credit to you and
your your training
your uh you're off the field work um
hey rich have a great time man i'm glad
that it's it's it's back to normal
uh uh hopefully you guys work out the
weather situation whatever the case is
gonna be
everybody's gonna be watching there is
no better team
covering the nfl draft in your team of
daniel jeremiah and charles davis and
you and kurt
uh can't wait to watch it man thanks
brother and thanks for
doing the show today i always appreciate
when you do it dan thanks man
absolutely thanks for having me his 17th
year covering
i think he's gone but uh what what a run
it has been and it will continue to be
for rich eisen chase did you hang up on
rich i did not
he hung up first that's all right hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here